>>presenter: Hello, everybody. Hi. Thanks
for joining us today. I'm really, really pleased
to introduce to you Loretta Napoleoni in today.
Loretta is a writer, journalist, and economist.
She is the leading expert on the relation
between our economies and terror, and that's
what she's going to discuss with us today.
We will have 30 minutes of discussion and
then another 30 minutes for Q & A. I believe
we have--
[Loretta coughs]
a lot to learn from Loretta's, from this session
today and from her book. So, I hope you and
Loretta as well, will enjoy the session. So,
join me in welcoming her and thank you.
[applause]
>>Loretta: Well, thank you very much for being
here today. So, what I'm going to do is tell
you a story and through the story, I will
show you how terrorism and the economy are
actually intertwined. In particular, what
I want to put forward to you is how the War
on Terror, which was launched by George Bush
after 9/11, has caused the credit crunch,
the recession, and all the tribulations of
the current economy.
And finally, at the end of the speech we'll
have a look at the future. And the danger
is that the consequences of this War on Terror
may actually be much more serious than the
crisis we have witnessed until today.
Now, why I told you, "I'll tell you a story,"
is because I think in order for you to understand
what is the economics of terrorism, I have
to start from the beginning. Otherwise, you
won't understand how this economy actually
has developed.
And I will tell you my personal story because
it is happened to me, about 15 years ago,
to stumble in to the economics of terrorism.
It's not something that I wanted to discover
or it was something that I was working on.
In fact, at the time, I was working as a banker
in the city of London.
So, it all happened about 15 years ago, I
got a phone call from a friend who was looking
after the rights of political prisoners in
Italy. In particular, we're talking about
the Red Brigades. The Red Brigades was the
armed organization which was particularly
strong in Italy from the 60s to the 80s. It
was a Marxist organization and--
[clears throat]
one of their characteristics was not to talk
to anybody, including the lawyers. So, they
sat through the trials without saying one
single word.
So, it was a bit of mystery how the Red Brigades
came about, how they were organized. So, in
1992, they declared the end of the armed struggle,
and they decided that they would tell the
story of how the organization was formed to
a group of people. And they made a list of
people and I was one of the people on the
list.
Now, you'll be surprised, as I was surprised
myself. But the reason why I ended up on that
list is because my childhood friend became
a leader of the Red Brigades. So, she was
arrested in 1978, I discovered, by opening
the newspaper. And there was her picture.
I didn't know anything. She had never actually
spoke to me about her political conviction
and to me, she was a perfectly normal individual.
And yet, she was one of the leaders of the
Red Brigades.
So, I stayed in touch with her, but we never
spoke about politics at all because she was
one of the unrepentant members of the organization,
so she was bound to silence. Anyway, in 1992,
when they decided that the armed struggle
had finished, she put my name forward. And
a group of female members of the Red Brigade
actually backed my name as potential person
to talk to because they met me at the time
I was a leader of the Italian Feminist Movement.
Of course, I didn't know that they were members
of the Red Brigades. This is the life we lived
in the 1970s in Italy; your best friend being
a terrorist and you didn't know.
[chuckles from audience]
Anyway, so, now this proposal came at a very
difficult time of my life because I just head
a management buyout of the company I worked
with so, I was very busy at the time. Plus,
I just had a baby so that was the last thing
I wanted to do was to go back to Italy and
tour all the high-security prisons, meeting
people I haven't seen since the 1970s.
But, in the end, I actually decided to do
it. And the reason why I did it, is because
I wanted to know why my best friend from the
age of six, had never tried to recruit me.
Why she actually never asked me to become
a member of the Red Brigades. Now, you'll
be surprised again, but the truth is that,
at that time, the way the organization worked
was to recruit people primarily among member
of the family and best friends. So, why not
me?
So, I went back, and I learned very, very
quickly why I was not recruited. I actually
had failed the psychological profile of a
terrorist. So, there's a group of people who
decide if you are the right person to be recruited
or not. So, it came out that I was too single-minded
and too opinionated to make a good soldier,
which is true.
So, but it was at that point that I realized
that perhaps, terrorism, it was something
totally different from what I had read in
newspapers, or what we actually had discussed
in the 1970s.
So, I got more and more in to investigating
why they recruit people and once they recruit
people, what do these people actually do?
And what I discovered is that, in reality,
a terrorist organization is run like an army.
There's a very small group of people -- the
leaders -- that actually run the show; all
the others follow orders. And these orders
are always based upon searching for money.
So, what the average terrorist does, all day
long, is find money in order to fund the organization.
There's no discussion about ideology. There's
no discussion about politics because once
you get in, you're already indoctrinated.
So, when I was asking members of the Red Brigades
why they decided to fight against the state
in a certain way, they actually didn't really
know how to answer me because they had no
idea. I mean, of course, the leaders is a
different thing, but the people that actually
did carried out attacks on a daily basis,
they had no idea. Once I start asking them,
"Well, tell me how did how did you manage
to get the money? How did you fund the organization?"
then they were really happy to talk to me.
So, some of the stories were amazing. For
example, there was one guy who was a psychiatrist;
he was a part-timer. The Red Brigades had--
[bird chirps]
500 full-timers at any time and then they
had about 2,000 part-timers. So, the people
who basically did carried out a normal life,
and then they helped the Red Brigades on the
side. So, he loved sailing. He had a beautiful
sailing boat. So, what he did in the summer
was to sail back and forth from Italy to Lebanon,
pick up the weapons from the PLO, which, of
course, came from the Soviets, carried back
the weapons in Sardinia, and then various
organizations, for example, ETA or the IRA,
will come and pick up their share of these
weapons.
And for this service, the Red Brigades received
a fee. So, he was very happy to tell me that
because he thought it was a great idea. Plus,
he was having a great time sailing. So, this
is where I thought, "Well, maybe there is
something more to terrorism than ideology.
Maybe, well, what I really need to investigate
is the economics of terrorism."
So, the idea to actually do a research in
this field came after I had lunch with Mario
Moretti. Mario Moretti was the leader of the
Red Brigades when Aldo Moro, the former Prime
Minister of Italy, was kidnapped. He was actually
the guy who executed him.
So, I had lunch with him in one of these high-security
prisons. And while I was talking to him, I
know it's, but this is why I want to tell
you this story because it's an amazing story.
So, while I was having lunch with him, I had
the distinct feeling that I was back in the
City of London having lunch with a banker.
This guy spoke the language of finance so
well. And the way he expressed himself, he
was a true manager. And he was explaining
to me how he was managing his company, which
happened to be called the Red Brigades.
So, this is where I thought, "Well, that's
it. This is what I should be doing." I'm an
economist. I mean I'm trained in the economic
terms. I worked a long time in the City, so
this is when I began my investigation. And
I must tell you it was very difficult to find
anybody to fund my research until 9/11 because
everybody thought I was completely insane
to talk about the economics of terrorism.
So, I funded myself and I did the right thing.
So, what did I discover? Well, I discovered
that since World War II an economic system
has been created by armed organizations. And
this economic system has gone through three
major evolutionary stages.
The first one is the state sponsor of terrorism,
the second one is the privatization of terrorism,
and the third one is the globalization of
terrorism. So, to a certain extent, this economy
has been following the evolution of the international
economy and eventually of the globalized economy.
So, what is the state sponsor of terrorism?
Well, this is when the two superpowers were
fighting a war by proxy using fully funded
armed organizations at the fringes of the
sphere of influence that they controlled.
So, we're talking about the Soviet Union on
one side and the United States on the other
side.
So, what was the modality? Well, basically
these armed organizations were funded with
legal and illegal activities. And I think
the best example, of course, is the Contras
in Nicaragua. So, we have the US Congress,
who actually funded a certain amount of money
to support what were considered "freedom fighters."
And then because this money were not enough,
we have the Reagan Administration launch a
series of covert operations in order to fund
them.
So, that's the mix that we're basically going
to find. So, another interesting characteristic
of this stage is the fact that these groups,
these armed organizations, did not fight their
own wars, but they fought this war by proxy.
So, they basically fought whatever the superpower,
the sponsor, wanted them to fight. This situation
changed at end of the 70s, beginning of the
80s, when terrorism was privatized.
And the guy who actually did the first privatization
was Arafat. So, he managed to gain independence
from his sponsor by setting up the same kind
of system; so, a mix of legal and illegal
activities, but controlled by his organization
-- so, by the PLO. Now, and the results were
fantastic.
I mean, we see that, for example, there are
some documents coming from the CIA where they
list that the amount of money that actually
are produced on a daily basis by the PLO,
and it's higher than the GDP of some of the
small Arab countries. So, they actually did
very, very well.
So, this is the phase of the privatization
of terrorism.
Another example, nearer to London, for example,
is the IRA. IRA did the same thing. So, we,
so that the IRA controlled all the transportation,
private transportation system, in Northern
Ireland. So, every time somebody got into
a taxi in Belfast, without knowing, was actually
funding the IRA. The Orange, were, in the
construction business, so every time somebody
actually remodeled his flat in Northern Ireland,
in reality, was funding the Orange group.
So, this is how much terrorist organizations
managed to penetrate the legal economy, the
everyday economy.
So, the last evolutionary stage is, is the
one that we know better which is, of course,
the globalization of terrorism because this
is the one that created an organization like
Al-Qaeda. Now that happened in the 1990 with
the deregulation of the international financial
system. All the barriers came down, so countries,
I mean, armed organizations, were able to
link up with each other in a much better way
than the one I just described to you about
sharing arms.
So, they started to do business with each
other but also, they started to do business
together with criminal organizations. They
money launder, the dirty profits, through
the same channels. So, we see the birth of
a new international economic system. Now,
Al-Queada is very much the stereotype of this
new phase because it is an organization which
was able to fund itself cross-border. So,
the portfolio of somebody like Osama bin Laden
was an international portfolio.
But, so was the portfolio of Arafat, but the
difference is, of course, Arafat was focused
on one single part of the world, which was,
of course, Lebanon and Palestine, while Osama
bin Laden was actually looking at the global
world. So, in other words, 9/11 was a transnational
attack, which was funded in different parts
of the world. It was put together; it was
planned in one part of the world, Afghanistan,
and was carried out in a different country,
in the United States. Now, we have never seen
anything like that. So, that is the, the product
of this globalization of terrorism.
So, what I did before 9/11, I actually calculated
the size of this economy. So, this is an economy
where we find three main components. So, the
first components is the illegal economy, which
is described as "capital flights." This is
a jargon to describe money they move from
countries to countries, undetected, unreported,
and illegally. So, bribes, which go from one
country to another, but also tax evasion gets
calculated into this. So, and this is 500
billion dollars. Then there is, there is the
Gross Criminal Product. This is money generated
by, by criminal organizations across the world.
So, we have from petty crime to organized
crime, which is another 500 billion dollars.
And then we have what I have defined as the
"new economy of terrorism." So, these are
money that are generated only by armed organization.
And one part is, of course, illegal, but one
part, which is about one-third, is actually
produced by legitimate businesses.
So, people that are part of an armed organization
who fund this organization through help from
families, for example, but also, through work
that they carried out. And I think a good
example of this is the attack that was carried
out on July 7th in London, where most of the
funding was legitimate. People had either
worked or used their salaries or used help
from their friends. So, there was not criminal
money coming in in order to fund this attack.
So, in total, we're talking about 1.5 trillion
dollars, which is about five percent of the
world economy as it was in the year 2000,
or more than the GDP of the United Kingdom.
So, we're talking about a lot of money.
Now, what was interesting, actually, is that
when I went to look at where did this money
get recycled because most of this money is
dirty money, so one way or another, it has
to be washed somewhere. So, what I found out,
that the majority of this money was denominated
in US Dollar, and it was actually money laundered
inside the United States. So, this has very
serious implications in economic terms.
I'll try to explain to you if you don't understand
in the question/answer, you can ask me. But,
what's happened is this; imagine all this
1.5 trillion dollars moving every year inside
the United States. Now, this goes straight
into the US economy, so it actually sustains
the US economy. But more to the point, because
it sustains the US economy, so it helps the
US economy to grow, it has an impact upon
the US money supply.
The US money supply is the amount of cash
that every year is printed by the Federal
Reserve in order to meet the demand coming
from the economy. So, the higher the growth
of the economy, the higher will be the number
of bank notes that the Federal Reserve will
print. So, I went to look at the US money
supply to see what was happening because,
of course, what I thought is, "If this money
come in and have to be money laundered, one
way or another, some of this money have to
come out in order to go back to the origin."
So, imagine a Columbian drug dealer, he wants
his money back; he wants his profit. He's
not going to invest all the money in the US.
Part of it has to come back and then with
those money, of course, he will buy weapons.
So, with those money, he will sustain the
growth of the illegal, terror, and criminal
economy -- our 1.5 trillion dollars.
So, I went to look at the US money supply
figure and what I noticed is that from the
1960s onwards, an increasing amount of cash,
which is printed every year, left the United
States, never to come back. Now, these are
money that are taken out of the US in suitcases
or bulk shipments or in containers. And I
discover that many economists from the Federal
Reserve's had written extensively on the topic
warning the government that something was
majorly wrong. Where are all this money going?
And, of course, this money went to fund the
terror, criminal, and illegal economy. So,
this is, this is how the circle of money actually
gets closed.
But what is very interesting is the fact that
the United States, as a country, was benefiting
from this flow of money. Not only because
the money was coming in to be money launder,
but above all, because the United States can
borrow against the total amount of dollars
in circulation in the entire world. Not only
against the amount of dollars in circulation
inside the United States. And this is because
the US is the reserve, I mean; the dollar
is the reserve currency of the world.
This privilege in economics is called the
seigniorage. So, the country that has the
reserve currency can borrow against the total
volume of dollar. So, this is explain why
the United States can have a debt, which is
enormous in terms of any other nation, but
it is allowed because the US has the dollar.
So you see how important is the dollar for
the US? So, what this research implies is
the fact that, in reality, the United States
had been borrowing against the growth of the
illegal, criminal, and above all, terror economy.
So, it was actually borrowing against its
own, the growth of the economy run by its
own enemies. So, --
[clears throat]
this was quite shocking. And, but the situation
changed with the introduction of the Patriot
Act. See, after 9/11, if you remember in October
2001, the US passed a legislation which was
called the Patriot Act that reduces greatly
the rights of citizens inside the US in order
to protect them against terrorists. But, there's
a section, which is a financial section. In
this financial section, --
[microphone noise]
what the, the government actually posts is
a prohibition to all US bank and US registered
banks to do business with offshore facilities
-- so, offshore banks. That means that it
block the entry of all this dollars into the
United States. So, it was, in reality, an
anti-money laundering legislation.
At the same time, it also gave the US more
entirely authority -- the power to monitor
all dollar transaction taking place all over
the world. Now, the Patriot Act completely
changed the way money flowed from one country
to another country.
And, and I'll explain you why. It was first
of all, extremely unpopular among international
banks because nobody wants the US authority
to monitor what you're doing with your client.
It, plus, of course, according to the Patriot
Act, if a bank failed to report of a suspicious
transactions taking place anywhere in the
world in dollars, it could be criminally persecuted.
Now, you may remember that there are several
banks, for example, Lloyds and UBS, were actually
have been fined by the US authority on the
basis of the Patriot Act. So, what did the
banks actually do? The banks started to advise
their clients to get out of the dollar investment
into euro investment. And that explain why
all of a sudden, from October 2001 the euro
start shooting up and the dollar start falling.
Now, the same thing, of course, happened with
illegal and criminal money. The criminal organization
did exactly the same thing. They said, "Ok,
we can't money launder anymore in the US.
Well, you know, let's go to Europe."
And then Europe was an ideal location because
we just got a new currency, the euro, which,
so, the, the, the way the European euro was
functioning was ideal. There were no barriers,
they were not controlled from one country
to another, the market was large enough, the
euro was a brand new currency. And above all,
we did not have any legislation, any an, anti-money
laundering legislation or, or any legislation
similar to the Patriot Act.
So, each country had different legislation,
but they were very weak. So, in reality, the
Patriot Act, instead of stopping terror money
being cir-, circulating around the world,
but also money laundering, it simply shifted
the epicenter of this activity from the United
States to Europe. Now, but, at the same time,
terrorism kept growing, in reality, from 9/11
to date. We have frozen only 125 million dollars
of terror money. The majority of this money
have been frozen in the first six months after
9/11.
Now, in 2005, I chaired this group of experts
on terrorist financing and we worked for six
months, basically tracking the money in order
to find a solution to the problem. And what
we did, we actually put forward a proposal
whereby the, the Patriot Act was gonna be
scrapped. A start of an international body
was gonna be created in order to monitor the
transaction of different currencies, not only
of the dollar.
To bring about a sort of cohesive international
policy, in order to fight terrorist financing,
and the Bush Administration, of course, who
which was in power at the time, did not even
take into consideration even one of this suggestions.
So, it was, to a certain extent, a waste of
time. But, but the problem remained because
the Patriot Act is still in place.
Terrorists, as you know, has not stopped.
On the contrary, actually, the terrorist activity
around the world has increased, and the unit
cost of a terrorist attack today is much lower
than it was in 2001. Now, if you think about
the, just executing 9/11 costs about half
a million dollars, the attacked took place
a few days ago in the tube in Moscow probably
costs a fraction, an in, a very small fraction
of that amount. So, we are still facing this
problem.
Now, the reason why all of this is happening
is because the Bush Administration reaction
to 9/11 was very much single-minded. It was
also unilateral reaction, so the United States
decided to pass the Patriot Act, did not consult
anybody, they did not talk to the Europeans,
who actually had the much better understanding
of terrorism and its finances.
But the reason why all of this happened is
because, in reality, the, what the Bush Administration
really wanted to do was not so much bring
Osama bin Laden to justice or stop terrorist
financing, as much as implement a plan which
was a plan to relaunch the role of America
within the international community as the
most important and hegemonic power.
Now, all of this is contained in the Project
for the New American Century, is, is a blueprint
of the vision of the future of the neoconservative,
which was created under the supervision of
Dick Cheney. Among this project, we find one
key point, which was the decision to go into
Iraq to bring about a regime change at any
possible cost.
[clears throat]
So, 9/11 became a sort of opportunity to carry
out this kind of policy. And therefore, in
2003, we actually went to war in Iraq on the
basis of false information. Now, what I wanted
to reflect now, and this is what links this
story to the present is how did the US actually
funded this kind of war and very, very strong
economic effort? As I told you before, the
money laundering was not any more, any longer
in circulation inside the US economy.
The truth is the funding took place by selling
government bonds in the international markets.
So, basically, getting into debt. And I remind
you that Bush came to power in 2000, we doubt
about the deficit claim, on the contrary,
Clinton left a very small surplus. So, the,
the best way to sell government bonds on the
international market and be competitive is
to cut interest rate. If you cut interest
rate, the value of the bond rises. Now, from
9/11 to the summer of 2003, when they thought
that the war in Iraq was basically finished,
interest rates in the United States goes from
six percent to 1.2 percent.
This is the time in which we find also, the
bubble of the subprime taking place and inflating
beyond any imagination. This is the time in
which banks, because they had the interest
rate basically coming down continuously, started
to give free credit to everybody, including
to people who actually could not afford to,
to get it. So, that's the link we find between
terrorism on one side, and the current crisis.
In reality, the, the bubble burst because
the system had been based upon a constant
diet of low interest rates, and this is when
the world economy was actually overeating.
This is a, took place at a time in which,
actually, interest rates should be increased
instead of decreased. Now, so the, the credit
crunch very much is related to the fact the
United States needed desperately to place
this kind of debt, in or-, we're talking about
four trillion dollars. This is the debt accumulated
during the Bush Administration from 2001 to,
to basically the day he left the White House.
But then what is the relationship between
this kind of debt and what is happening today?
I mean, today we see that the relationship
between the United States and China is getting
tougher and tougher.
This is quite risky for the world economy
because we are on very shaky ground. The reason
why we haven't gone into a major depression
is because one country, China, has continued
to grow and has continued to supply us with
cheap products. And the reason why this relationship,
at the moment, is shaky is based upon the
fact that the country that bankrolled this
four trillion dollars needed by the US to
fight this war, is actually China. China bought,
up to 2009, up to 75 percent of the issue
of treasury bonds of the United States. In
2010, it's gone down to five percent. So,
the US is actually funding its debt either
domestically or through other countries -- Japan
being one.
The tension between the two countries is based
upon, as you read in the newspaper, it's based
upon the willingness of the US to do anything
to force China to unpeg its currency to the
dollar. Because, of course, the Chinese do,
have pegged the currency to the US dollars
in order to defend the kind of debt they have
accumulated.
So, imagine if the renminbi appreciates and
the dollar depreciates all those four trillion
that the Chinese actually have, will lose
in terms of value. It's very easy to understand
that. But, at the same time, of course, pegging
the renminbi to the dollar allows the Chinese
to comp-, to continue to be competitive with
their products on the international market.
While the US dollar, of course, coming down
as been very, very good for the US exports.
In fact, the trade balance is positive when
the trade balance was actually negative in
2005 and 2006.
So, the policy of the US, at the moment, is
the policy of a country, which is really in
a big, big trouble and it's desperately trying
to solve its economic troubles by imposing
certain kinds of condition to other countries.
And these other countries, because today,
as China is the case, because today are much,
much stronger than they were in the past,
are basically saying no.
Now, this is very serious. Meaning, if we
go down the road of protectionism, which is
exactly what is happening, and it's not only
the United States, it's also -- Europe is
doing the same thing, in order to defend their
own, our own products from the cheap Chinese
products. And if the Chinese retaliate, as
they've done, and I think the Google story
is very interesting, because it's taking place
in a particular moment in which the relationship
between China and the United States are at
a very low point.
I mean, the Chinese, I just came back from
China, I was there for three weeks, the Chinese
are trying to impose harder and harder condition
to western business in order to do business
in China as a sort of retaliation for what
is happening in the United States. So, it's
a very delicate, very delicate situation.
So, to conclude, I think that if we go down
the protectionist route, if this relationship
between China and the US, which are vital
for our economy, actually fall apart, we may
risk to end up in a situation very similar
to the Great Depression. The Great Depression,
in reality, was not caused by the crash of
'29. It was actually caused by the protectionism,
which was applied after the crash of '29.
Now, we if go down that road, the truth is
that Osama bin Laden will have won this war
because the reason why 9/11 took place is
to destroy the power of the United States,
not only in economic terms but also in political
terms to destroy that role, that symbol, that
the United States always had of democracy
and freedom.
And if we go down the protectionist route,
I am afraid that this is what is going to
happen. And I don't think we should let this
happening at all. I mean, we should do something
about that because otherwise, we would live
in a world that will not be the one we know
as being reshaped by an individual, Osama
bin Laden, and a bunch of religious fanatics;
you know the terrorists. Well, thank you.
[applause]
>>presenter: You willing to take some questions?
[pause]
>>male #1: Thanks, that was really interesting.
Just a question about, so, you ended the note
saying that we should really do something
about this. How do you balance, well, the
internal pressures coming from the United
States from the different lobbies to protect
their production within that, with the need,
and for the United States to get better relationships
with China? Also, you've given the fact that
the United States is, it's a government which
is, I can't, what, the electorates and they
have their own pressures, whereas the Chinese
can really afford to take much longer term--
[clears throat]
much longer term positions on that policy.
>>Loretta: Well, I, I think that an organization
like Google, for example, can do a lot because
you, you're on, you're on the Net. I mean,
I believe that most of the true information
actually circulating on the Net is not through
the newspapers anymore; people should be educated.
Now, the story I told you, it is quite complex,
but it's not very difficult to understand
and yet, I haven't read the story like this
in any newspapers. I mean -- nobody is linking
this, this phenomena. But the truth is that
you can link it using data and using economic
information.
For the US, I'm afraid that Obama has very
good intention, but the people who are advising
him are the same people that in the 1990s
did the deregulation. So, the, we need a major
change of also of advisor -- a new vision
of the economy.
And the truth is that the US should accept
the fact that perhaps it's not any longer
the most important economy and take some steps.
One could be to reorganize the monetary system.
I mean the dollar can't be the currency of
the world anymore. We can't have a reserve
currency, a currency, that depreciates regularly,
month after month after month.
I mean, people that hold that, that currency
in the end, you know this is why gold has
gone up so much. I mean, a lot of people,
in fact, are buying gold in order to protect
themself because the dollar is coming down.
The euro is doing the same thing. So, I mean,
it's quite serious situation, so I would think
that the best thing would be to get economies
together and politicians in order to have
a new Bretton Woods whereby China plays a
very important role. But I don't see this
happening. I mean there's not that willingness
exactly as in the 19, the 1929 crisis.
[pause]
>>male #2: Thank you very much for coming,
it's very interesting. One question on terrorism
because you mentioned the, the cost of carrying
out 9/11 and then the cost of, the relative
cost with carrying out the bomb attacks in
Moscow. I'm always surprised, too, when these
news come that actually this is not happening
more often, and I wanted to ask you w-, w-,
do you know why that isn't? If I were a, a,
a terrorist I would be doing things like that
every week. And I--
[laughter]
I think they have, they have the means and
they definitely have resources and the people--
>>Loretta: Now, that's a very good question.
>>male #2: to do this.
>>Loretta: Well, I mean, something like this
happens every day in certain countries. Pakistan,
for example, Afghanistan, Iraq, so what we're
seeing after 9/11 is the concentration of
terrorist activity in a part of the world
which, of course, there was not terrorists
before. So it's ok, but Central Asia and then,
of course, the Middle East where we have terrorists
for
[clears throat]
decades. But the reason why they're not doing
so much is because they're not very good at
it. So, the organization I described you,
the Red Brigades, doesn't exist anymore. I
mean, today the model of a terrorist organization
is very, very different. So, it's a virtual
kind of terrorism. A lot of these people get
recruited through the Net, they actually don't
go through a proper training, they don't go
through the selection that I was rejected
to, right? So, they are amateurs.
I mean, think about that guy, for example,
that the, the, what was it? The 26th of December
was lighting a match on a plane, sitting next
to three other people in order to blow the
explosives that was in his shoes. Why didn't
he go to the toilet to do it? I mean, you
know this is; I know this seems very logical
to us, but a lot of these people are fanatics.
A lot of these people are not very smart.
That's why they get recruited and this is
why they get indoctrinated.
>>male #2: Actually, there's a big correlation
between fanatism and just plain stupidity.
>>Loretta: There is. Absolutely. I mean, to
be honest, I, of all the people I've interviewed,
I mean I also interviewed members of the al
Zarqawi group for another book I wrote and,
and most of them, to me, sounded not very,
very smart. But, then you get the leaders
who are really smart but yes, who would become
a terrorist? I mean, terr-, it doesn't really
make sense. Yeah, I, does it make sense to
become a terrorist? Have you ever seen a terrorist
actually succeeded in doing something? Yes,
you, you have a situation like Fidel Castro,
but it's a completely different context. Anybody
there today thinks that can bring down the
United States or the United Kingdom by blowing
himself up in a tube; it's stupid. It's not
gonna happen.
[pause]
>>male #3: Just following that train of thought,
did you find more about why your friend joined
the Red Brigade?
>>Loretta: Oh, yes. My friend joined the Red
Brigades because she actually thought that
Italy was a block democracy, which is true,
I mean we have the same government for 35
years, and today we'll continue to have the
same government for another 35 years. Only
the name of the leaders changed.
And she thought that the only way to unblock
the, the democracy was through the armed struggle.
But she was recruited by her boyfriend, and
apparently she was targeted by this guy. So,
this guy was trained in order to seduce her,
to recruit her, because she worked at the
Ministry of Defense, and she was the person
in charge of the route that every day a group
of key politician took in order to go to work
from home. And you know she got 35 years in
jail for that. How stupid can you be?
[pause]
>>male #4: You mentioned the three stages
of terrorism: state sponsor, privatization,
and globalization. Can you try and have a
guess at what's, what the next one will be?
>>Loretta:
[laughs]
Well, I think what is happening now actually,
is a sort of privatization within the globalization.
These small groups, I mean, for example, the,
again, going back to the Moscow attack which
is the most recent. Apparently, those two
women had been recruited through the Internet.
They received very, very basic training, and
they self-funded themself.
So, I would say that this is a sort of privatization
model, again. The same thing is the Ju-, the
July 5th here, July 7th.
They also, the Madrid attack, to a certain
extent, was the same. I mean, the idea that
terrorist organization are funded as it was
in the 1980s and 1970s by sponsor is actually
not what is taking place, especially in the
west. Now, we do find some groups in Iraq
which receive money from Saudi Arabia. For
sure, we have sponsor that are sending money
in Pakistan and Afghanistan, but these are
different kind of terrorism, I would say.
These are actually borderline with separatist
kind of fighting with the civil war, because
this is clearly the situation in Iraq.
But, talking about the kind of model that
is supplied in our country so, in the West,
I would say that we have a sort of privatization
within the globalization. And it's cheap because
you know people get very scared. But y-, y-,
you know, the Moscow bombing was on the front
page of every single newspapers and for 24
hours, it was the most important news.
And, so, this is the impac-, impact of 9/11
you know because 9/11 was such a tremendous
event that got stuck in our subconscious.
So now each time something similar happen,
you relive that kind of terrorist mastermind
attack, which, of course, is not the case.
But and the government, of course, help a
lot because instead of rationalizing, instead
of saying no, in reality, as we've said before,
that these guys, in reality, are not doing
it very often.
So, either they're not good, or we are very
good, but one way or another we're winning
on this front. The governments use this terrorist
threat in order to scare us because they have
learned by scaring us, they are able to make
us accept certain kind of policy that we would
never accept otherwise.
[pause]
>>presenter: More questions?
>>female #1: Yes, I was wondering, as we mentioned,
that you, that you rose a daughter and so
on, what's your opinion on the role of, of
the UK? Also, taking into account that there's
an election coming.
>>Loretta: Within terrorist, maybe?
>>female #1: Yeah, and economy. What do you
think of the UK economy situation?
>>Loretta: Well, the UK economy-
[laughs]
is in very bad shape.
[audience laughs]
>>Loretta: That's for sure. Well, I, I, I
think it would be interesting to watch the
campaign in the next weeks because, you see,
to a certain extent both parties they have
to justify the presence in Iraq. And this
is going to be a key issue. Although, the
justification is very much on ideological
terms.
We are, you know, protecting freedom and democracy
and whatever, not in economic terms. But,
one thing is sure and the public opinion now
knows that the reason why we have so many
casualties it is because the UK soldiers did
not wear the protective equipment that the
Americans have. And the reason why they didn't
want to wear the equipment until recently
is because they were underfunded. They were
underfunded also in terms of weapons; they
were underfunded in terms of equipment, helicopters.
So, it'd be interesting to see how this particular
aspect of the war, because running a war for
a long time is extremely expensive, and even
if this war is only fought by professionals,
the war is very expensive. So, i-, in a moment
like this, where we have major recession taking
place in which the UK economy is not really
taking off, I would say that none of the economies
is taking off, because the data that came
out yesterday about Germany also are extremely,
extremely negative. There's a very high number
of small to middle size companies in Germany,
which actually have closed in the last six
months. Because there is not sufficient credit
to sustain them, so I would think that something
like that, the justification of a war that
is so expensive and we're not winning.
Plus, a war that was, that was born out of
a pack of lies should be on the table in the
electoral campaign. But, I doubt it, it's
any of the two parties; I'm talking about
the Conservative of course, and Labor, won't
touch that topic because if they do, it may
turn out to be the Pandora Box. But, backfire.
>>male #5: The US is out of Iraq, I mean UK.
>>Loretta: Sorry?
>>male #5: The UK is out of Iraq.
>>Loretta: No, it's not.
>>male #5: Mostly out.
>>Loretta: No, no, no, no, no.
>>male #5: But they're not in combat actually.
[laughter]
>>Loretta: Yes, they are. They are in combat.
I, I can guarantee you. Y-y-y, you can use,
see the bodies coming. I mean -- these guys
are in combat. I mean--
>>male #5: You're talking about the war in
Afghanistan.
>>Loretta: No, no, no. I'm talking about Iraq.
The UK is at war and it's shoulder to shoulder
with the US. It's the second largest contingent
after the US.
[pause]
I promise you, unfortunately.
>>presenter: Ok, we've got another question
here.
>>female #2: Well, first of all, thank you
very much and I feel that it would be great
if more people were aware of what you just
explained to all of us here today. I would
like to know your opinion about the role that
the media is playing in this war of terror.
You've talked about the changes that you would
like to see happening in the economy. Today,
the media have succeeded in, in giving us
lunatic reasons behind the war of terror,
one of them being religion, of course. What
would be the major changes that we need in
our media landscape for this to maybe change?
>>Loretta: I think the media is very much
responsible for this failure to communicate
to the world really what is happening. But,
in all fairness, I think that in certain countries,
the situation is better than other countries.
I mean, clearly, if you talk about a country
like Italy, the media is controlled. So, yeah,
it's very much, you can say.
But, in this country, the media is less controlled.
And I think one of the main problem is the
fact that today journalist has to work much
more than he did in the past so he has less
time to do a proper research and on top of
that, the spinning, because you know this
is all linked to spinning, the spinning came
at the moment in which journalists were desperate
in order to fulfill all the different tasks
that they have to do on a daily basis.
The 24-hour media, for example, so, in all
fairness, I don't think the media, particularly
in this country, but also would say in the
US, has done purposely a bad job. I think
the media was just ill-equipped to do the
job properly, and continues to be so. Because
to do this kind of research, I mean, I told
you, I mean I started my story 15 years ago
in 1993, basically. So, it takes a long time
to understand the intricacy of the system
also.
>>female #2: Isn't that a media choice at
the end?
>>Loretta: Well, I don't think it's a choi-,
I mean, I think if you are employed, I mean,
if you're employed by The Observer today,
for example, The Observer they say it may
close, but it used to be a very good paper.
But if you're employed The Observer and you,
the only way to keep your job because you,
there are no money is to write instead of
one really good article every two weeks with
a serious research, but 15 mediocre articles,
what are you going to do? I mean you will
do the mediocre.
And if somebody like Alastair Campbell calls
you and invites you to a nice breakfast and
spins you, you know, you gonna take those
news and you gonna print it. So, it's the
problem is the system. The problem is, I think,
that the printed media is disappearing. Something
new is coming out, which is on the Net, and
we are in this transition and unfortunately,
these horrible events took place during this
transition.
And people believed, see everybody believed
what, what the, the leader told. I mean, who
would've thought that Colin Powell, when he
went to the Security Council in February 2003,
actually said one lie after another. I mean--
>>male #6: That was in the newspaper. The
same thing, that it was all lies.
>>Loretta: Was it?
>>male #6: Yeah. The UK--
>>Loretta: Well
>>male #6: The UK has left Iraq, by the way.
>>Loretta: Sorry?
>>male #6: The UK has left Iraq. I tried to
Google it, gone to Wikipedia, whatever.
[audience laughs]
>>Loretta: The UK has left Iraq?
>>male #6: Yes.
>>Loretta: Well, maybe Wikipedia has been
hacked by the Chinese also, yeah?
[audience laughs]
Every is possible. Every is possible. But,
I don't think that unless you have they left
in the last two hours, I don't think the UK
is not in Iraq anymore.
>>presenter: On that point of debate, thank
you very much, Loretta Napoleoni, it's been
a pleasure having you here, and thank you
everybody for coming.
[applause]